[Musique]
bonsoir des amis j'ai l'impression que
le temps va changer il y a beaucoup de
vent dans le ciel ce soir auront brûle
que le pauvre
je ne pense pas du tout le pauvre petit
mot chapeau monde au japon où petit
woerth où j'ai bien peur que le vent les
emporte est bien loin ton chapeau aux
pauvres aux chocs
je veux mon but tu sais pas pr neil il
est très beau cet étui pour mon pipeau
il est tout en carton peint regarde les
miennes et qu il est tout au tissage
tiens mais j'apporte mon dos qui l'a
fait entrer votre petit pas preneur j'ai
perdu mon sort soit non tiens la flotte
au chapeau bon chapeau ou bon jeu petit
show qu il était plus qu abbas est tout
petit chapeau claque d'or noir je suis
si content de l'avoir retour
[Musique]
non non c'est toi moi même je peins le
flou pourquoi vos abonnés du raja pour
monsieur homéopathe marc et pourquoi pas
c'est très chic cas en regarde comme un
sur un chapeau de monsieur regarde les
hommes j'ai compte toujours des plumes
sur leurs chapeaux et des fleurs allons
ne bouge pas nous nous il faut souffrir
pour être au bout et voilà encore une
fleur ça y est une autre shit
merci le petit j'ai un beau chapeau je
veux son tu nous dis pas bonnes nuits
sonores
aujourd'hui leurs enfants merci pour
beau chapon
non
bonne nuit nicolas bonnet par e mail
thor bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais voilà notre nounours avec un
chapeau plus beau qu'avant au trot j'ai
bien cru tu ne te perds plus mon cher
pour ce n'est pas bien grave
le vent a joué une blague nul n'est pas
méchant le vent comber botro le cocan
bonne nuit des enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents et allez vite vous
coucher à demain fait pour eux